gare de dépenses d'économiser et
pourront faire guégot monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur premier ministre le
mercredi 21 septembre
un homme d'une vingtaine d'années fichés
s a été interpellé après avoir été
signalé par un étudiant en raison de son
comportement suspect devant l'université
de rouen cet homme il y avait déjà été
aperçu à plusieurs reprises au cours de
ces derniers mois
âgé de 18 ans de nationalité française
il a été mis en examen et placé sous
contrôle judiciaire
une semaine plus tard le mercredi 28
septembre
il a été interpellé en bulgarie à
proximité de la frontière avec la
turquie et a manifesté clairement son
intention de se rendre en syrie
madame la ministre de l'éducation
nationale a indiqué la semaine dernière
qu'il y avait plus de 600 signalements
d'élèves soupçonné de radicalisation en
tant que vice-président de la région
normandie en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur je vous ai adressé un courrier
en date du 23 septembre dernier afin que
vous communiquer précisément les
personnes fichées s aux présidents
d'université comment se fait-il qu'une
personne fichée s connu des services de
renseignement puissent tranquillement se
poster à plusieurs reprises aux abords
d'un établissement d'enseignement sans
être inquiété comment sous contrôle
judiciaire
arrive-t-il à échapper aux radars au
point d'être interpellé en bulgarie
contrairement à la réponse de monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur fait à mon
collègue laurent wauquiez la semaine
dernière il ne s'agit en rien de faire
peur mais bien de confirmer confirmé une
réalité qui vous dérange tous les moyens
ne sont pas mises en oeuvre pour assurer
face à ces menaces terroristes la
sécurité de nos concitoyens et tout
particulièrement celle de nos jeunes
étudiants après l'assassinât atroce du
père mail à saint-etienne du rouvray
ce sont bien les normands qui ont peur
alors ma question est simple
monsieur le premier ministre à quoi sert
ce fichier s
s'il ne veut même pas contribué à mettre
en place des mesures de surveillance
efficace mais si la parole est à
monsieur jean jacques urvoas garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée je pensais que depuis le temps
que nous parlons de ce sujet il était à
peu près compris par tout le monde
les fichiers s alors je vais le redire
les fichiers s
c'est un morceau d'un gros fichiers qui
s'appelle le fichier des personnes
recherchées dans lequel il y a quatre
cent mille personnes
les fichiers s est donc une subdivision
c'est un outil administratif qui est à
vocation préventif ce n'est pas la remet
la plus absolue du pouvoir arbitraire
comme aurait dit mirabeau en parlant des
lettres de cachet donc ce sont un
élément de police qui sert uniquement à
indiquer qu'il y à une mise sous tension
dans le cas d'espèce dans le cas
d'espèce que vous évoquez qui part d'un
fait sur lequel vous avez parfaitement
raison
ce jeune homme était fiché s il a été
mis en garde à vue il a été placé sous
contrôle judiciaire et avec moi
j'imagine que vous vous le féliciter que
parce qu'il a rompu son contrôle
judiciaire il a été interpellé parce
qu'un mandat d'arrêt a été lancé par un
juge d'instruction et que ce mandat
d'arrêt a été appliquée et que la
personne est aujourd'hui placée sous
l'autorité de la police donc dans le cas
d'espèce c'est parfaitement convenable
tout ce qui s'est passé contre
judiciaire mais pourquoi il est parti
peu m'importe il a été interpellé une
fois qu'il n'a pas respecté son contrôle
judiciaire que vous mettez un peu lié
s'il n'y avait pas eu d'action de police
je comprendrais mais là on est dans un
cas parfaitement rigoureux il a démontré
la virtuosité du système
j'insiste sur le fait que l'autorité
judiciaire ne peut placer en rétention
que s'il ya des éléments de preuve le
fichier n'est pas un élément de preuve
le conseil d'état vous l'a redit le 15
décembre
vous ne voulez pas l'admettre nous
continuerons à vous l'expliquer
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux la
parole et à mesure il